we turn off the music avoid any
copyright claims so it's midnight
actually it's three minutes before
midnight
back in Chicago area more normal time
zone for most people last several weeks
have been very crazy I've been traveling
all over the place three weeks ago I was
in Thailand I traveled through Singapore
New York City I was in downstate
Illinois for last few days now I'm back
I'm hoping to do some more regular
streams at least this coming week this
will probably be a quick one I would
like to play a stroke because he's also
streaming and I think it would be fun
for people to watch like if if we both
stream
he's playing one minute so what I'll do
is I'll watch his games and then I will
sorry I got distracted
someone just subbed oszi nation chest
just subbed Wow
Thank You znation chess that's awesome
what was I saying I'm gonna watch a
Sook's games and then hopefully play him
and it'll be a streamer streamer bullet
match or something if that doesn't work
then I'll play random people and maybe
I'll do tactics or whatever hero hero
hero hero
what does LM life master yeah which is
just a u.s. title I think there's like
life master and life senior master but
it doesn't really meaning anything like
internationally I don't think okay let
me get all the windows where I want had
his way to wait is audio working okay
audio should be working let me
do that and yeah let's try and play a
snook create game one minute is he
playing maybe I can just challenge him
like directly oh I'm playing someone
else okay
that's too bad I'm playing another LM
that's cool he's playing a perk I
haven't done too much streaming with one
minute and talking so it might be
difficult to talk and play but I'll try
my best
that was a good move that was a bad move
okay now why has a bishop hair be five
maybe take
man I have so much respect for people
who can talk and play one minute I'm so
down on time the position doesn't look
that great
actually the position looks ok let's do
this in g3 I don't know I didn't want to
give up the bishop hair but okay let's
just try and simplify Queen for two
rooks it's probably easier to play with
the Queen just one pea story about is
you gonna hang something let's chat good
yeah let's check first do that take Oh
I hung something but he didn't take it
this is so bad okay now White's just
lost that was a good move okay nice else
tell me myself probably not Queen g1
please no okay
Queens you one more the pin check anyway
okay that was really bad I think it was
better at some point but talking and
playing one minutes it's not easy
what happened in that position
like everything was hanging but I had
the check but blacks feel better too
many things attacked I should have liked
work f1o but thanking me seven okay
let's forget about that game let's try
one more time to place play a stroke and
then if that doesn't work I will do
something else to go
just homepage I could watch his stream
on my stream that lets go to this link
and then watch games so he's currently
playing a game so if I challenge him
would that work
one minute I haven't been looking at the
chats but okay
I've been gonna continue to look at the
chat because we're playing a streamer
vs. streamer good luck ace rook there's
gonna be less talking and more playing
Queen c2 is weird when you usually
doesn't belong on c2 I should have
played a five you should have played
before
[Applause]
okay Queen c7
[Music]
and yeah les les commentary than last
game for sure but I'll try and give some
moments of insights when I can well
actually be better here up upon and I
just wrapped his night Paul but he has
stupid tactics take take that's really
unfortunate
mmm Oh 95 okay that took too long to
find let's take that
so hero hero hero hero wants me to play
against viewers which I'll probably do
at some point
oh my gosh this is gonna be annoying um
[Music]
subs long yes it's long it's not too
annoying okay that was fun it's fun to
win it one-minute display the two nights
attack hope he doesn't know this
I actually meant to play a three there a
four makes some sense well but now I
just lose a piece okay this is bad but
at least White has a D file and good
center but a piece is a piece
oh this is really bad just down on time
down a piece try and complicate things
somehow get some quick attack ins
against the king v6 is weak f2 is weak
okay
I went some material back one c3 and
still down on time I have two pawns and
the rook for the two pieces before
almost wraps and nights Wow
coming back here push that be pong take
take take know he has 96 and let's do
this and then b7 take take take
okay that works
whoo that was a really bad start of the
game but somehow I came back like he
just he tried to simplify it but lost it
talk a lot of material quick moment to
read the chat loons Master what's up sea
nation thank you thank you thank you
okay rematch so the score I guess and
includes the previous games that we
played completely five this game and I
got three so this is some slow
positional line
oh no moobot g5 does that work no he is
95 ah I have to turn you about off um
can I like bad moobot unmod okay I'll do
that afterwards this is actually kind of
annoying so I couldn't play g5 there
let's try for f5
do that that and c6 some weird structure
the black has a lot of activity coming
on the kingside
that's a good move
King is kind of stuck in the center
I know which king is less safe mm can
take right
it's crazy position can get still okay
for lack though especially if he's
thinking
mmm let's do this does that mean oh
that's not mate oh look he flat okay
okay three four three Flash Gordon 22 I
am back actually returns to the US on
February 1st but I can't I through I
flew through New York
stay there food for a few days let's
wait tirage this game old school opening
I play this line before I think you
should be too
yeah ii e5 I don't think that works so
definitely didn't work what is he doing
all those free pieces oh he meant to
play Bishop c5 by rematch okay
nice score so far mixing up the openings
play this whatever setup reversed ba
Phoenix system
at some point I'll stop this match and
use something more productive but it
feels good to keep the streak going
another crazy short position we're both
trying to attack on the kingside that's
annoying that's also annoying let's sack
its Queen c6 so I'll be weak on the
light squares oh he can't defend you for
that's nice
I just make him feel stuck oh that
doesn't quite work let's play that
I just want to play rook F lung and
torture him actually let's take him down
clear epitaph for now
okay znation chess how have your travels
been they've been really hectic but I do
have an article coming out either
tonight probably tomorrow on on US chess
just recapping the last two months of my
life let's play D for this game go for
some London system C for Queen b3
yeah very positional line
Brook a sudden weird move
if I could play b5 because there's a pin
a very thematic idea try and keep it
positional
it's a very classic positional grind
these London positions
37 No
let's take
that wasn't not necessary the defense
this was bad what's going on
oh my gosh please flag before I flag
No okay um
that was really messy I don't know how I
let that slip I just got to relax I'm
planning to execute anyone who plays the
London as against me from now on it's a
good idea hello you die four four four
hello jaga left we'll play a few more
games until I want to play play c6 seems
where the Slav be greedy up upon
and Bishop here
some point I want to play c5 very soon
doesn't quite work
[Music]
his nights are annoying my bishops
really bad won't be sudden
this is scary
No I'm so slow it's been a while since
I've played bullets with just hands get
sweaty with the trackpad okay um no more
excuses let's play another London this
line again
we're very similar to the previous game
slipping
so funny structure
but very pleasant for whites they play
on the Queen side and the Kings side oh
I didn't mean to do that though still
interesting because his rook is kind of
stuck he's going to move the bishop to
d8 it's still interesting oh that was a
good move
have to flag him somehow such a funny
position what's going on
we finally takes
kingi six was critical because i think
he probably pre moved
King takes e5 I was a crazy game I was a
really weird position like he had to
somehow get his rook out but he was
stuck and he he was very hesitant to
take because he didn't want me to win b7
okay I'll try and get to 10 points and
I'll stop so I have 7 and a half right
now we're actually six and a half given
that's only today's score age six I
still have to kill robots
this is probably going to be a long game
so time is very important especially in
these close positions being sneaky
I don't see mates but it looks very
close
you're just winning materials good
enough
at the core move coming up the double
pin that's nice
and loops on the draw arrows there let's
do that
that was a weird maneuver rook to b5 but
his palms were weak
okay I'm gonna unmod moobot I could ban
you about uh-huh just in the back move
on ok i'll unban him eventually okay
rematch yeah I would suggest if whoever
is watching this watch both of us I'm
sure it's much more interesting to get
both perspectives let's play Knight of
three this game some sort of English
ready
it's a weird opening my queen
and Bishop is almost trapped on that
five okay weird stuff is about to happen
take-take-take i want to sack my queen
but it's wrong spending too much time to
know I I wanted to take on V - mm-hmm
slight now slip let's try and fight
though still fighting chances win the
Queen down a rook F twos weak
download time
good move
okay keep it going
still trying to get to ten points this
line this line is interesting
my clock is being super greedy but it
might pay off
you might take on f6 it's almost losing
now I feel comfortable because it's hard
for him to remove this night which
defends g7 43 comes give you that and
that's okay looking good
have to move quickly though
okay
i rematch
okay what opening to play let's play
English ooh
caro-kann this is just a bad opening for
back
no I wanted to play a for all the smells
slipping today
rook lifts
the bishop moves are coming to Bishop
threats looks fun
let's take
that's a fork
mmm my teacher Sam is here welcome Ches
127 crazy ba bad words okay
I'm not gonna pay too much attention my
teacher Sam is Ahmad so if there are bad
words
my teacher Sam can step in let's go
firma ROTC binds me b6 is okay he would
like to take on e5 but my recon aid is
defended
I'm gonna go for a sneaky mate bye chief
for a night h3o now it's removed I'm
still threatening made into think I can
go for that
when f2 that sort of works
that was a good move sack my queen
nights are so tricky
ooh good move
this would be scary if he got stuck into
age six but okay time has been treating
me well I am using a trackpad my teacher
Sam it's my only source of moving the
cursor
I used to use these wireless Mouse's but
I kept losing the little USB stick so
it's hard to lose a trackpad this is
some sort of Greenfeld something oh I
passed ten points I didn't even realize
if I win this game it'll be my last game
so I do want to end with the win
good move
very good move
mmm he's playing well stop it he's
playing fast too
No okay I resign
okay rematch last game for me I better
win this one
good luck let's play a good openings for
this know you played h4 let's play h5
this is a little bit symmetrical
[Applause]
hmm
at four is a great square for a night
okay ice games ace rook it'll be cool to
go back and like watch his stream in my
stream and see the mash-up what is going
on okay I'm trying to catch up with the
chat Eric where did you go after
Indonesia so Don X for me I went to so
after Indonesia I went to Phuket
Thailand then I went to Singapore for a
couple days
then I went to London for three days and
then I went to New York City and now I'm
back in Chicago
hello breathing how's it going Ace rook
hi hi very messy games except that last
one at least I think I kept it clean at
least for my my side any other questions
I missed okay people don't believe me do
people believe me that I'm on a trackpad
this is a trackpad but the Mac trackpad
is it's good it's really nice
what's the setup from black you don't
like facing the most not London I don't
know if I want to give that away
but because the nation chests did
subscribe let me give it away I do I do
have to encourage subscribers so see you
nation chests let's make a new study
learn study new let's just call it
crashed
this is completely public so feel free
to do whatever with its dust oh I'm
gonna stop watching these rook Yomi H
hello long time no talk
okay so London for black actually I just
want to use a game to demonstrate this
and the game is some turn and I played
in Denmark so Eric Rosen extra time was
the last round I just got completely
crushed as whites I forget the name of
the guy who I played maybe this link
will take me yeah Schroder he was so
well prepared for me I was completely
unprepared for him so just a quick trick
with beach s if you find a game on chess
games calm and you want to bring it into
Lee chess the easiest way is to when you
make a new chapter go to URL just paste
the chess games link create chapter and
it's magic
so Wow it's really hard to keep up with
the chats and talk but let me let's just
focus on this this is how I got crushed
over the summer and I will say if I know
what someone's gonna play this line then
I will probably choose a different
opening but for whites
I played London knight c6 and I think
I've shown this in some like YouTube
lecture video where a lot of people will
play c3 here as whites and I guess we're
going over this for black so we'll look
for blacks perspective if white plays c3
this is probably the most common sort of
London position and then black is very
happy after Queen b6 given that B twos
under pressure and I think this is
already equalizing if I plays Queen B 3
C for Queen c2 a very nice move for
black Bishop f5 and I have drawn into
this line in depth multiple times so I
think all I'll leave that that if if
white does play c3 just know to play
Queen b6 in this game I played 92 which
attempts to meet Queen b6 with a
different idea because now the book is
already defended and the idea is to
sacrifice b2 so well I played in this
game this D takes e5 and I thought it
was like a fun line for whites if whites
well prepared but what I didn't realize
is if blacks well prepared it's also a
fun line for black and my opponent was
really well prepared he took on b2 rook
e1 taking on a - I should mention is
very risky there's a lot of lines where
the Queen could get trapped but very
simple Queen c3 threatening c5 I was
like Bishop b5 and then
I will admit that like what my opponent
did I think was very strong and I was
about to say that liked what my opponent
did I liked it from the black side but
not from the white side he doesn't take
on c5 immediately if he takes on c5 I
would place before I think there's
compensation for whites what he did he
played just ecigs
and kind of delaying any immediate
breakthrough from whites and the game
continued castle and he just played
Bishop e7 I think he was still in this
prep night b3 castle it was actually a
really difficult position for white
because even though it's equal material
and like whites fully developed the pawn
is just really weak on c5 and the queen
is actually really annoying on c3 that
was hard to take advantage of and from
here I started using a lot of time I
think I played Queen Queen d3 94 I was
just so unpleasant like 94 was so strong
I can't really take as he would take
back and stuff would fall Brook c1 might
be four I think by this point black was
already crushing yeah like -2 already so
anyway I think that's a useful line to
know a lot of people won't need to know
like that deeply but if you're looking
for some set up against the London at
least know this Queen b6 move with idea
of target and b2 so I think I'll leave
it there I'll look at the chats probably
what I'll do is wrap this up relatively
soon I might do some tactics or if
people want to play me feel free to send
me a challenge I've been playing the
Cairo as a meme
what and have a higher win rate than
Sicilian okay how do you move so fast
with the trackpad I mean I've been using
a trackpad for like most of my life and
if you watch me use a mouse you'll maybe
understand why you started streaming at
ridiculous hours of the night
it's 1244 am a ridiculous hour of the
night well I wasn't I wasn't Asia in
Australia for a good portion of the last
two months
so it's always gonna be ridiculous for
some people epic Mouse is named trackpad
okay well we're gonna move on one of the
reasons why I'm streaming or I'll be
streaming next few days is because I
have a tournament coming up next weekend
and I'm trying to hold myself
accountable to actually study for that
and I'm gonna do my best not to play too
much one minutes so I'm gonna try and
like solve at least a handful of puzzles
everyday and I do have a nice streak
going on me chess so I'm gonna stop
looking at the chats let's minimize this
and just focus on the board I'll try and
saw it as solve at least five and then
we'll see how I feel from there
so have to readjust from all that bullet
I just want to take on you for like
blitz of us but black to move before
actually looks really attractive this
simple removal of the guard like before
if the knight moves I win e4 with a fork
if white plays e5 I take and I attack
the bishop on d2 so V 4 has to be the
move and will take the pawn it keeps
going
really so there's a couple choices
there's 94-98 both look okay actually
I'm wondering if there's a problem like
with one of them I mean 94 is probably
the better move just a lot more
aggressive I'm surprised it's actually
playing it out because 98 looks
reasonable to my blacks just up a piece
I'm trying to find like some tactical
problem like 1980 Queen c2h6
but 94 I mean 94 Queens YouTube it
should be seven let's play 94 so just
curious if Knight e8 was there anything
wrong Queen b3 but it's still better for
black but maybe there's some comp
usually 98 the 98 is not a piece that
you want against a pawn on e5 and now
that could match up there so okay fair
enough let's move on black to move and
this looks kind of bit like importance
fact the Queen's attacking the knight
but we can't easily deflect the White
Queen on 93 or Kennedy might be four
looks attractive threatening the fork
what's material whites up upon but black
has most of the pieces in the game
yeah night before it's not like a
forcing check but it has a very menacing
threats which I don't know if I can stop
night before
I mean the best move removes that I see
are either King e2 or Queen f4 but then
there's got to be a massive compensation
so let's play night before then we'll
take the bishop and then take the knight
okay
easy peasy let's move on it's a crazy
position equal material lots of focus on
e5 and take without the 995 can take
with the rook on e5
it's also some potential like 90 to
interference checks I feel like the
theme is like interference or
obstruction where we want to block the
at least this rook on on money one so
let's calculate 92 if work take you to
fish at a key to we win the exchange and
if white takes back on YouTube we take
on e5 and we're still up the exchange so
92 Bishop take e to I don't know if that
actually does anything for black might
actually lose a piece there should take
me too
okay never mind 92 is probably a bad
move
yeah this is trickier is there just a
really simple I didn't even consider
Knights c2 but it might run into bishop
take g7 what just happened oh right c2
Bishop to g7 team take G Sutton Oh the
bishop defends the rook some might see
to turn black and white survive probably
not
night see to rub g3 but then we can take
on e5 okay let's play nice you two it
took way too long to find my died see -
don't know what happened there
whites being tricky though I didn't see
this line but it's nice this rook is
pinned to the other rook so I think just
keep me chains
alright King h8 take take should be good
enough okay I lost count I think those
three problems I think what I'll do I'll
look at the chat after two more problems
trying to keep the streak so weird
position I'm just curious how this what
opening this was this is from some like
randomly chess game some Sicilian this
night as usually a monster on g5
okay interesting position so if 95 then
it's equal material no black supple
plump okay so blacks up appalling here I
mean would like to take on each seven I
don't think there's any other like
candidate move we can also try and trap
the rook on a to somehow but that seems
difficult so night a cage seven keen to
gauge 725 check King g8 then f6 threaten
Queen g5
that looks good so f6 black would take
we want a rook lift just so rook up
three and I think white is just meeting
it's the type of thing if you had this
in a game you have to be absolutely
certain this is working
make sure black has no escape I don't
see any escape take take when h5 f6
I think it's really important that after
f6 Queen g5 is a major threat so let's
go for that uh-huh
that's a good sign okay one more
whoa what is this is this so white was
in 1923 playing a for a fortnight c3
Knight a - well probably some novelty
opening this is actually a classic kind
of opening trap idea where we just take
on f2 and then Queen h4 and Queen d4
actually Ronald reminds me of like some
garbage opening in the Sicilian let me
just show this real quick we just go
back yeah
so wait I move the pieces I can't move
the pieces in a puzzle okay real quick
garbage opening this is how you can beat
unsuspecting players who play the
sicilian efore c5 Bishop b5 most people
will play a six here and then you play
Bishop to c4 turn off the engine and now
a lot of players will play b5 like why
not just kick the bishop again expand
but then the trap is you take on f7 it's
the same theme and take Queen age five
Queen g5 take on AIDS and the King has
nowhere nowhere to escape to if it goes
to f6 or six is uh there's mates so g6 I
wonder how many people have fallen into
this on me chess Queen h5 opening book V
chess so about 50 games man it's sad
person
don't play King f6 but g6 but black wins
the majority of the games really II 6
Oh cuz black might be trapping the Queen
Wow I guess if you if you're trying to
play this for light you have to know how
to escape with the Queen which maybe
isn't so clear and I thought this was
like a garbage opening but maybe it's it
requires some deeper analysis stockfish
black is better Wow
okay never mind if anyone plays us as
whites go into this line is black
because blacks just much better here I
guess
the Queen just can't escape and
stockfish knows best
yeah actually it might just be very
simple like Queen c7 Bishop e7 okay I
learned something new I thought that was
like I've known this for a few years and
I just assumed this is better for whites
I guess not
okay lesson learned
I'll look at the chat real quick but I
think I'm gonna end it
I've been streaming for about one hour
and I'm tired it's been a long weekend
but I'll be back like I'll be back
probably tomorrow and the next day and
then the day after that I'll be I'll be
doing some twitch for the protest League
match so that should be fun I'll look at
the chats you were crushing in Melbourne
blitz yeah
jagged up bringing up one of the
interesting stories from my trip where I
was leading uplet's tournament and I had
to withdraw to catch a flight very
depressing
okay people trying to solve tactics
spinal tap chess who is spinal tap chess
I think it's Tom pretty sure it's Tom
hello Tom
znation chest should probably be a
mother
wowsie nation chess is gonna have like
three badges subscriber mod and twitch
prime okay yeah I'm gonna end it here uh
get some sleep and I'll be back and more
awake in the future have a good night
guys or a good morning wherever you are
I guess